let's quickly check these out and see if
they look good if we agree with them and
where they come from okay so you need to
use a variety of techniques to get all
of these different pronumerals and
that's part of what I just wanted to see
if you were able to manage at the moment
you guys know when you often get an
exercise in a book the exercise tells
you what school you need to use every
single time it's like this whole
exercise is about Pythagoras so you kind
of get in sort of Pythagoras mode and
you know every single questions can be
related to that idea right but in sort
of more real-life situations you get
problems and you don't know what
knowledge is required or what skill
that's part of the skill working out
what's required so when you have a look
at these you need to sift through all
the tools in your toolbox and work out
which one you need start with number one
what do you use to work out H this one
is Pythagoras that's why I use that as
my first example five squared plus
twelve squared does equal 13 squared
because it's a right-angled triangle so
you've got a leg there fantastic now you
don't actually need that length to find
out theta you could have found sorry I
rub that up you could have found theta
first how would you have done it if you
didn't know what H was how would you do
it yeah was it okay so you would write
your line before this and by the way
I've made sure the people up on the
board I didn't require you to put down
working because I didn't give you heaps
of space but you in your book or in an
exam you absolutely have to have work
because I need to know where this angle
came from and also for your own sake if
this is right or wrong how do you really
know it's kind of like a black box of a
moment where did this number appear from
like what what's the reason for it you
have no idea so the line before this
would be as ry as i mentioned would be
to do with ten y-tan because if this is
your position and you look at these two
sides one's opposite and the other is
adjacent and that's that's ten so this
would be the lion preceding your answer
if you don't have that line in your
working can you please put it down it's
not enough to think that use your
calculator and then
don't answer okay you've got to show the
working is 22 degrees 37 minutes okay do
you go with that yep great let's have a
look at this one now alpha alpha doesn't
require any trigonometry in this
triangle what could you use what
knowledge can you use I think I heard it
yeah the angle sum of a triangle right
because you've got these two angles and
that gives you the third one another way
of thinking about is in a right angle
triangle these two here they have to be
what's their relationship again starts
with the C they're complementary very
good they add up to 90 not supplementary
that adds up to 180 so that gives you 43
degrees here is Daniels air turn I point
33 how would you get that number
what's again what's the preceding line
or what's a preceding line you can have
10 of 47° so again we've chosen opposite
and adjacent because that's the sides
that you're near by and it's important
that you get this order correct right if
you wrote eight over ten adjacent over
opposite you'll get a completely
different value for a okay
now just before we leave off this
question to do the last one I've
emphasized all the way through this year
that every time you get an answer you
have to do what's called a sense check
right every way you possibly can you
can't always but what's the time you can
does this answer make sense given the
context now it's nine point three three
that's pretty pretty close to ten would
you agree
does it make sense that these lengths
would be pretty close to each other or
do you expect one to be much longer than
the other let me ask this question
another way right if you guys agree that
we should expect this number to be close
to this number my next question is why
why would you expect them to be like in
the same ballpark yeah Daniel yeah
fantastic that this told us that it's 43
and 47 those are very close to being an
isosceles triangle do you agree and so
therefore you're going to
have something closer to have the legs
to an isosceles triangle there's one
other piece of information
suppose I was punching my buttons on my
calculator and I got say ten point three
three okay now that passes the first
sense check because it's close it's in
the same vicinity but there's something
else that can tell you this can't
possibly be the answer even though it's
in the right ballpark can someone tell
me without any calculation of any kind
why 10.33 can't make sense
any suggestions Jake you've your arm is
like half up do you want to venture
sighs yeah okay just give that muscle oh
yeah okay what do you think huh so let
me let me try and restate what Aaron
said cuz he's got the kernel of it but
some of the bits are a bit confusing in
it um in a triangle right this is the
whole idea of trigonometry in a triangle
the angles and the sides are related
they're connected together okay when you
have an angle and a side that's opposite
they're related in this is very closely
connected way if you have a big angle
right I've done this with you before
just take your two hands and imagine
they're the sides of a triangle right
now if you put them close together like
this okay you've got a small angle
between your hands do you agree you got
the small angle there now have a look at
the side that will be opposite that
imagine your two fingers your index
fingers joining a side it's a small side
right small angle small side now as you
widen that angle well have a look at the
side that you're creating the side
between your two fingers a wider angle
means a wider a longer side does that
make sense okay so now when you come
back to this diagram see how this guy's
47 so the sign that's this angle is
bigger than this angle so the side
that's opposite has to be bigger than
this side 10.33 question mark you're
putting a bigger side opposite a smaller
angle that doesn't make sense it's
contradictory okay
so that's another kind of sense check
you can use and it will come in handy in
about three lessons time so remember
last one x equals 28
what's the line before that what's the
line before X equals 28 we're going to
use a ratio I think I heard it if we
could use cosign okay cause of X is
going to be equal to adjacent on
hypotenuse okay
now once you do that once you get X you
don't need to use trigonometry to find Y
or the other way round right what's the
relationship between these two angles
same one before they're complementary so
you can get the the next one without any
calculator work at all